[Music]
Luke Tom name Jacob and Rebecca here
with the outdoor boys YouTube channel
and we're in York England in the UK and
we are taste testing all of the
different British peanut butter spreads
and chocolate spreads and there are many
and they are diverse in nature and
flavor and we are excited are we boys
yeah I'll also tell you my sister
Melanie is off camera
say hi Melanie but you can't see or so
I'm going to keep her quiet and mute in
the corner where she belongs
I'm sorry the kitchen is really small I
can't get the camera to pan the whole
table what do you want to try it first
all right we've got M&M with crispy
pieces that's my pieces right there just
one Pinot unfortunately my wife Rebecca
is allergic to chocolate so she will not
be tasting this one that looks good
let's have these little crunchy bits in
there you know a crunch bar how's that
little crunchy like rice pops in it it's
like it's like Nutella with that in
there alright okay we're gonna try a
basic British peanut butter and see if
it's any different than American peanut
butter
mr. choc smooth peanut butter it smells
and look like looks like American peanut
butter but it's a little bit thicker now
that's different and I don't like it the
difference no sugar in it another peanut
like it doesn't have a really strong
peanut flavor
butter that won't melt it's got this
boilie lingering taste in your mouth
that is not doing okay we've got Cadbury
crunchy spread yeah oh my goodness
that smells decadent I got to be the
bread there's a chocolate one not to
check little crunchy bits do you think
there's a caramel in it like best chips
yeah pretty good I'm gonna start ranking
these I'm gonna lay them out in order of
our preference of it we got crunchy
almond butter here whoa this is very
separated so we are going mix that back
up I'm not going to try dad what spreads
easy enough it just drips onto the bread
really it looks like she ate baby poo
she's making a face but not it's like
super liquidy but it stinks to your
mouth really bad the boys have fled the
table Melanie looks like she barked in
her mouth and Becca has been polite the
Cadbury milk chocolate spray look at
that that is decadent oh my goodness
that's like they've literally nothing
down oh yeah yeah that is that is
straight-up liquid chocolate you know
that would be good on everything
ice cream sundae but yes let's do some
Marmite this is fermented yeast extract
who wants to try some of this bread
fermented yeast extract it's kind of
like reddish caramel that tears the
surface off the bread
here's the Marmite it just it's like a
salty chemical spill is what it tastes
like it really doesn't taste like this
should be food plunge it is the world
for Marmite all right that gonna give
the Marmite ago wipe all this Marmite
off that we can't you can't risk
contamination okay we're trying the
crunchy maple peanut butter it's from
the same company that made the almond
butter and it is super runny it tipped
over and has spilled a giant puddle of
goo all over the table we probably won't
get our security deposit back but that's
okay it's for science
dandy the maple is very weak in it so is
the peanut butter flavor it's not bad
but it's just really sad icky and bland
you know the Marmite has destroyed our
taste buds all right who wants to try
some cashew butter never was a
that's what's not as bad as the other
it's a different brand - we're checking
out of our rental house today and we're
gonna leave behind like 20 jars of
various bread spread didn't plan
that doesn't plan to a whole new level
this is beige on beige oh it's so sticky
have you were to give this to me blind I
could not tell you that I would catch
you in now Oh still stuck to the roof of
my mouth that I can't get loose I'm
putting that above Marmite but below but
below the other peanut butters I know we
need a rebound how about the duo choco
spread planned ass I swear scooping
frosting out of a jar here do a
precision scoop on the white part just
the white no that's kind of buttery they
finally melts in your mouth it's coming
at chocolate and vanilla frosting I like
I like this better than so many others
just because it's not as overpowering
what are you looking at are you allergic
to birds will you take an Oreo and eat
the cream out of the Oreo just yeah
you can eat more cream snappier places
okay I've got crunchy Marmite peanut
butter spread here seven British guys
said you know what our peanut butter
sucks
our Marmite sucks we should put them
together and see the face like oh it's
so separated oh look at that
buckle up buttercup like I don't this is
for science Melanie yeah I kind of like
this because the bridge peanut butter is
kind of bland it well it's super bland
right and the Marmite is overpowered so
I took tomorr mate actually does give it
some flavor not necessarily a good
flavor but it's something you know I
would say this is better than the other
peanut butters we tried I know their
worst British peanut butter as salt like
had a baby together okay last one here
we have the whole earth smooth peanut
butter this is the no sugar added
if British peanut butter is just not
bland enough for you if you think you
know what this could use even less sugar
then this
what you grabbed it looks better than
it's more spreadable yeah it's it's
actually quite spreadable and it's not
separated which is surprised me it
tastes more like penis than the other
peanut butter yeah which is actually
surprising but it's definitely bland I
bet it'd be smeared some Cadbury on this
see let's add some sugar and see how we
go with that the best one yeah I would
put this smooth natural notion grand
above all the other peanut butters but
below the chocolate spreads yeah sorry
alright let me give you a quick overview
of the rankings from favorite to least
favourite your the duo chocolate spread
and hand the Cadbury the crunchy spread
the M&M spread the smooth peanut butter
the pine nut maple butter
the British peanut butter the almond
butter the cashew butter Marmite peanut
butter heaven Marmite which is the poop
thing well thanks for watching guys I
hope you enjoyed this video if you want
to see more videos from the after boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe and if you want to see tons of
videos from our three-week tour of the
UK check out the link in the video
description we'll make sure you get a
chance to see that as well thanks for
watching guys have a great day if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys YouTube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like that don't forget to click some
stripes
see other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that belt like you'll
get notifications thanks for watching